sixteen days into the nationwide
protests against the contentious
citizenship law and the women of Shaheen
bargain New Delhi are undeterred by the
26 dead arrests of a thousand and the
biting cold the police say they are only
maintaining law and order and deny
trying to quell the protests some of
them violent these women say they feel
threatened by the police and accused
some officers of committing what they
call atrocities Shaheen Kosar is leading
the female protesters the women are
protesting for their safety and to
protect their children fear has taken
hold of them since the clashes so they
want the government to come here and
assuage their concerns but no one from
the government has come to protest
against the controversial citizenship
law they say the violence used by the
police to suppress the protests
including beating up students in a
nearby university let them hear and
since Shaheen Cassell vividly remembers
the events of 13th December the day she
says policemen first thrashed the
students of Jamia Millia Islamia
University with sticks
the children of many of the women
protesters study there she says she's
never seen them so angry and scared as
they rushed to help
syadaahally is a women's rights activist
who has long experience of working with
Muslim women
she says the police brutality and the
unjust citizenship law have forced women
even from relatively conservative
backgrounds to step out and protest
never never have I seen this kind of
spontaneous outpouring of agitation and
protest by Muslim women they're afraid
for the next generation for their
children they are afraid that they may
become either refugees in their own
lands or they may be thrown out the
mother of success
police have pressured her husband to
stop her protesting she
is equally concerned by divisions within
the protest movement and says the lack
of leadership maybe just a windfall
India's government is looking for the
leader of the Congress party support the
protest along with other parties opposed
to the ruling Hindu nationalist BJP on
Saturday Rahul Gandhi visited the
northeast state of Assam where the
protests first began over two weeks ago
back in the capital the female
protesters say they're not against one
political party in favour of another
they just want the basic right to be
able to live safely and with dignity in
their homeland also Vora
al jazeera New Delhi